à Pékin pour la deuxième journée
consécutive des pourparlers se sont
engagés entre la Corée du Nord et la
Corée du Sud la famine au cœur des
discussions puisque la Corée du Nord
appelle à l'aide Séoul pour une aide
d'urgence en effet la pénurie
alimentaire touche l'ensemble de la
population reportage Isabelle Besler et
Tristan LeBRAZ donne donc est une des
portes chinoises de la Corée du Nord
elle est modeste son industrie discrète
mais semble une ville en plein boom par
rapport à l'indigence absolue de notre
rive même le Mao de Dan Dong tourne le
dos à pion Yang seul bouffée d'oxygène
pour la petite dictature un train par
jour et le pont qui apporte d'en
résumanitaire et marchandises atroqués
désormais les routiers chinois doivent
emporter leur gamelle car on ne trouve
plus rien en Corée du Nord
les gosses il faut vraiment pitié
il nous attend toujours de l'autre côté
du pont pour nous demander nos restes
par exemple on transporte une matière
première pour le savon mangeable un
produit industriel mais les gosses se
jettent dessus parce que ça contient du
beurre
même si elle voulait donner le change la
Corée du Nord ne le pourrait pas à cette
frontière pas une de ces rares cheminées
d'usine ne fument pas la moindre trace
d'activité à part un vague
transbordement saela juste l'hiver le
plus nu et le plus lugubre
il semble même que de plus en plus de
Coréens désespérés se réfugient dans la
clandestinité de famille coréenne de
Chine car leur état n'a plus rien à
distribuer la ration quotidienne par
tête certains pas 300 g de riz juste de
quoi survivre pas de quoi alimenter la
croissance d'un enfant
la se demander comment ces petits en
sursis trouverait l'énergie de chanter
les autres patriotiques qu'on leur
Martel
et c'est dans les crèches et les écoles
que les enfants seraient encore le mieux
nourri
seul privilégié
l'armée qui rend hommage régulièrement à
Kim Jong-il le fils du défunt dictateur
une armée toujours prête à en découdre
avec le sud et avec tout l'Occident
d'ailleurs une armée enquistée dans la
guerre froide